on sait pertinemment qui n'a pas de
poste à l'université
alors pourquoi est ce qu'on produit
autant de docteur la question est chargé
pour cette salle remplie de titulaire et
deux candidats au doctorat en 2011 60%
des doctorants souhaitait avoir un poste
de professeur à l'université mais moins
de 20 % étaient en réalité employés à
temps plein leur intégration au marché
du travail est donc devenu essentiel une
réalité qui rattrape la fiction comme
l'illustrent le plus récent film de
monia chokri tuer sans sûreté fille pour
tous les emplois ou que je dis souligent
et en même temps toute l'expérience
valoriser ce parcours académique c'est
justement la mission d'haddock qui
organise la soirée le cabinet de
recrutement se spécialise dans le
placement des titulaires de doctorat sur
le marché du travail
un mariage qui peut être périlleux en ce
qu on comptait les poteaux facile parce
qu'on parle pas nécessairement même
vocabulaire on oublie qu'on n'est autre
sauve qui lui fait pas et qui est
l'enfant le plein de s'offrir les
préjugés à l'égard des doctorants sont
nombreux sont particulièrement irrité
d'être considérés comme des étudiants
alors que ce qu'ils font est vraiment
plus de lors d'un travail d'un projet
d'une passion je suis gestionnaire de
portefeuille dont les 850 employés on
est trois dr que ce soit en finance ou
en pharmaceutique
le milieu académique vers lequel se
destine normalement les doctorants et
très hermétique
ils sont donc souvent considérée comme
déconnecté du milieu du travail
les recruteurs sont réfractaires quand
même à la qualification
une réticence allant parfois jusqu'à
demander de retirer de son cv ce diplôme
durement acquis si j'affiche un poste où
je demande un deck et que je reçois un
dock ça marche pas je l'engagerais pas
sur mon cv j'ai mon doctorat en bas à
gauche tout petit mais genre trop à
gauche ma liste de compétences
pourtant une étude publiée récemment
démontrent que 89 % des employeurs ayant
embauché des titulaires de doctorat sont
satisfaits de ses employés
chaque 2
doctorat qui est le premier ou la
première vraie dans un organisme par
exemple m'a prescrit un précédent écrit
de l'ouverture preuve que le dialogue
entre les milieux académiques et de
l'emploi doit se poursuivre et si
jacques andré charbonneau radio canada
mon frère